the Emmy nominations are out  and here are three sweet surprises that  we love  number one at these nods the nominees  for Outstanding Lead Actor in a comedy  series are tricky Alice no back yes both  blackish stars got acting nods versus in  two et was with Anthony Anderson right  after his amazing reaction to the news  have you stopped cheesing yet no I don't  think I'll stop choosing it all I don't  think I will  I don't think I will how does that feel  when you hear your name announced up  there what does that like you know for  something like this you know I I don't I  don't know I I can't I don't have the  words to explain that right now - Queen  B Beyonce's eliminated which aired on  HBO is nominated for four awards  including outstanding variety special  and the three voltage shows of finally  getting recognition if we move fast we  might be okay  the Americans has honours across the  board while orphan blacks Tatiana  maslany got her second acting nom in a  row surreal